今天我們要聊一個 Audi 的新車款，叫做 Nuvolari。這個案例很有意思，聽完可能你會想跟同事分享。
是的，Audi 最近發布了這款 Nuvolari，號稱是他們史上最快、馬力最大的量產車。它是一輛混合動力超跑，有 1,001 PS 的動力。
讓我感到詫異的是，現在電動車當道，很多車廠都全力往純電車發展。像歐洲在電動車上的累積投資都已經超過 2,000 億歐元了。
沒錯，Audi 自己也曾說要朝全面電動化推進。但在這個時間點，他們卻推出了一款以燃油引擎為主的旗艦跑車，這點其實出乎意料。
對啊，在大家都在喊電動化的時候，Audi 卻逆向操作，推出了這台混合動力的怪物。一般公司或人可能都會順應潮流，而不是這樣做。
從經營策略來看，這是一個很大的區別。他們沒有完全放棄燃油車的高性能市場，反而回頭強化這個區塊。
那它具體是怎麼做到的呢？這台 Nuvolari 的關鍵數字和做法是什麼？
這輛車的動力來自一個 4.0 升 V8 雙渦輪增壓引擎，搭配三個軸向磁通電動馬達。V8 引擎本身就能輸出 800 PS，而且轉速能達到 10,000 rpm。
哇，10,000 rpm 的轉速，這簡直是賽車才有的水平了。
是的，這已經是賽車領域的轉速區間了。三個電動馬達每個都能額外提供 110 kW 的動力，讓總馬力達到 1,001 PS。
這麼強大的動力，加速一定很快吧？
沒錯，它從靜止加速到 100 公里/小時只需要 2.6 秒，到 200 公里/小時也只要 6.8 秒。最高時速超過 350 公里/小時。
這種性能數據真的很驚人。而且它還分享了 Lamborghini Temerario 的平台。
是的，雖然平台相同，但 Audi 將輸出調得更高，並加入了他們自己的技術。比如一套叫做 quattro predictive ride 的系統。
quattro predictive ride 是做什麼的？聽起來很酷。
這個系統能即時處理轉向角、加速度、偏航率和抓地力等數據，然後協調電動馬達、煞車和空氣力學表面，讓它們像一個統一的網絡一樣運作。
這樣一來，車輛的操控性和穩定性應該會非常好。而且車身還幾乎都是碳纖維強化聚合物。
是的，這讓車身更輕、更堅固。還有主動式空氣力學表面，能根據需求調整位置，產生下壓力，這點也是受到 F1 啟發的。
所以，如果我是創業者或主管，可以從這裡學到什麼呢？
我覺得有兩個點。第一，別完全跟著市場一窩蜂。當所有人都往一個方向跑時，或許還有一些被低估的市場或技術值得深耕。
也就是說，就算大環境都在推電動車，也不代表高性能燃油或混合動力車就沒有生存空間。
第二，就是將現有技術推向極致。Nuvolari 不僅是混合動力，它還把 V8 引擎的性能、電動馬達的功率和先進的底盤控制系統整合得非常好。
這讓我想到，我們是不是也常常太快放棄現有產品或服務，急著跟風追逐新趨勢？
有時候是。其實把既有的核心競爭力，透過創新和整合推到一個新高度，也能創造出非常獨特的價值。
那對於一般上班族來說，這個概念可以帶入自己的工作或生活嗎？
當然可以。你可能沒想到，我們可以從「不要完全跟風」這點來思考。
怎麼說？
比如，當大家都去學某個熱門技能時，你是不是也能想想，自己原有的專業能力，如何結合新的工具或方法，做出獨特的價值？
我懂了，就像 Nuvolari 在電動化浪潮中，仍然把燃油引擎的性能發揮到極致一樣。我們可以把自己的「燃油引擎」也就是核心能力，用新的「電動馬達」來強化。
沒錯。還有，持續優化和深耕自己擅長的領域，不要輕易放棄。很多時候，把一件事情做到超越預期，反而能讓你脫穎而出。
這真的很有啟發性。不一定要全面轉型，也可以選擇將現有的優勢疊加創新，達到一個新的境界。
Audi 的 CEO Gernot Döllner 也說，這輛車展現了 Audi 如何將「Vorsprung durch Technik」（突破科技、啟迪未來）帶入新時代。這句話，值得我們好好思考。
的確。即使周遭環境都在改變，我們還是可以找到自己的定位，並將現有優勢發揮到極致。今天的分享就到這邊，希望大家聽完都有收穫。